hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between paul charles morphy and
daniel harvest but in order to continue
the match we must first abandon it and
go to our simultaneous exhibition a
blindfold simultaneous exhibition
against
eight different opponents and uh even
though morphe and harvest agreed that uh
if harvest takes that one break that he
can no longer take any breaks
as aside from uh sunday's harvest
disregarded that and as soon as he lost
the next game
after his break he again took a break uh
but for harvest
a breakman that he will continue as soon
as he feels like it
and he didn't really uh respected their
agreement but he still continued
uh playing chess against pretty much
everyone for
for a coin or two so uh as we are going
to return to the match
morphe is now leading the match we must
now go to the simultaneous blindfold
exhibition and here
uh morphe's opponent in the first game
not the first game
all of them were played simultaneously
the all of the games started at
around 12 30 uh in the afternoon uh but
this is the game that ended the the the
first so i decided to show this one
first and his opponent here
is a gentleman known only as pottier
and some sources uh say uh
pot here some some say something else so
i don't really know what uh is the name
of his opponent or what was it
but if any of you have any information
regarding this gentleman
uh do share and i will of course
highlight it uh so everyone else can see
but i think
to this day it is still unknown who who
this gentleman was even though
uh the other players of the simultaneous
exhibition are are well known
uh but i think they were they were
pretty much only members of the
versailles chess club so
uh i don't know uh we'll we'll get to
that uh so like i said
uh again all the game started at around
12 30
p.m maybe maybe even 1 30 not too sure
but around that time maybe a bit
afternoon
so here morphe with the white pieces uh
opens with
e4 as he usually does and morphe was
he wasn't feeling all that great he said
that it was probably something to do
with
the water in paris and that he uh wasn't
really feeling comfortable
if he had to go uh you know somewhere
else to the bathroom because then
players might say that
you know he's probably you know reading
the moves somewhere or
uh who knows no one has ever attempted
uh on the continent as
a blindfold simultaneous exhibition
featuring eight players and if you guys
are interested in what
uh all of this kind of looks like this
is
the this was the setting basically it's
a drawing from the newspaper so this is
one room there you can see morphe
uh with his back uh uh you know towards
uh
everyone else and the actual chess
players are in the other room so they
had to yell out moves
for the other players in that room to
see them but these are here spectators
some members of the media and you know
everyone else
who was curious as to what was happening
here which was quite a lot of people but
this was the
uh general general setting as they've
printed it in the newspaper so
uh after morphe's e4 the apothea goes
for
e5 we have knight to f3 and now knight
to f6
going for the petrov defense and morphy
immediately sacrifices a pawn with
bishop the sea fork
also known as the urushiol gambit uh we
have knight captures on e4
pottier accepts and now knight the c3
morphe
now offers another trade on c3 and this
one is a bit more dangerous to accept so
here
black goes back knight to f6 just to
give you an example of how dangerous
this is for example if black captures
white captures
this is one of those cases where you do
not capture towards the center but
rather away from the center to open up
all of the pieces now the bishop the
queen everything can come into the game
and already black has a very um very
real possibility of blundering the game
here
best boom for black is f6 and this is uh
this is solely for black
but if black isn't careful black might
play something like d6 and already
trouble is coming knight g5 attacking
the f7 pawn
and there's no good way to defend it you
have to defend it with some like bishop
to e6
but then we just capture that captures
captures and then queen to f3
threatening checkmate also queen
captures and b7 might be an idea in some
lines
and black is without a good move here
the knight is nicely defended here so
that's out of the question
and if you play something like a bishop
b7 uh ready to hide your king here just
queen f7
check king here queen captures with
czech king here
and something like h4 and we get this
very nice position where
uh black is the black is basically
without a move if you try something like
queen d7 to trade queens off let's say
queen f7 checking the eight now you even
capture here
and after the rook moves you're even
going to capture here and it's now a
completely winning position from
for white you have two connected past
pawns here you can just push one of them
easy
easy win uh just to illustrate uh how
dangerous a position can get very
quickly so here
apothea decided to go back he's not uh
even though we don't know who he is he
knows his chess
so here knight to f6 and uh here we just
have
knight captures on e5 so morphy grabs
back the pawn
and now d5 development before all
uh bishop back to b3 and now bishop to
e7 48 ready to castle we have d4 by
morphe
and now even c6 strengthening the center
a bit we have
castles by morphe and now knight beat to
d7 putting pressure on morphy's knight
here
and morphy immediately defends it with
f4
so that's a very solid move now of
course if you capture a white just gets
excellent
presence in the center here kicks away a
very important defender and then it's
not going to be easy for black to defend
so here
there is one game from i think 1996 uh
where castles was played
but here in this game apothy went knight
to b6 and it is only now as of move nine
that the disposition has never been
reached again
so morphe continues developing uh
developing pieces we have queen to f3
and now h5 here potay wants to play
bishop to g4
now the h pawn will also help with that
and morphe stops this by playing f5 and
this is just a beautiful move this is a
beautiful move that completely hems in
black's bishop
and it's uh well now it's a question of
how are
how is black to continue developing
pieces uh so here
queen to c7 and morphe just goes bishop
to f4 now threatening some very nasty
discoveries like maybe knight g6
attacking the rook
and the queen so bishop to d6
uh and now rook 8 to e1 and morphe
pretty much completed his development
now it's time to improve the quality of
the pieces for example this knight and
bishop
could move to more useful squares but uh
we will see to that later so here a
black might to decide to castle king
side
but potty rather goes king to a f8 he
still wants to use the rook
on the h file maybe for attacking
purposes so here
uh queen to g3 by morphy now again
uh threatening a lot of very very nasty
discoveries
maybe knight g6 check picking up the
bishop this would also win the queen
so here h4 attacking morphy's queen
saying that
this now uh simply doesn't work uh the
problem is
it does here morphy just went knight to
g6 with
check and there really is no good move
for example if you capture then bishop
captures here wins the queen
so you have to play something else and
the only move available
is king to g8 you cannot go to d8 the d8
square the e8 square is covered by the
rook so king to g8
and now morphe plays bishop captures on
d6
uh attacking the queen first now h
captures on g3
bishop captures on c7 and now f captures
on g6
grabbing morphe's knight if you go for
this in between g captures on h2
it's playable but not nothing really
happens for example captures captures
and
uh this is the position that arises so
instead after bishop captures on c7 we
have f captures on g6
but now f captures on g6 and um
okay uh maybe black is not down in
material all that much
but uh he is really really suffering for
squares the king is really
in a bad spot the bishop here slicing
this entire diagonal it's not going to
be easy for
for a good old uh portier so here
uh he goes bishop cap g captures an h2
with
check king the h1 and now you don't want
to
suffer because of any background
weaknesses so bishop to g4 now the rook
will help out with the control of the
back rank
uh we rook the e7 a very nice rook lived
by morphy
and now now comes knight beat to d7
and here uh you always can consider
something like rook to h5 this rook must
enter the game and also free up the h8
square for the king
uh but okay uh first we have knight beat
the d7
and now comes bishop to e5 and this
bishop to e5 is an extremely tricky move
uh because what do you play here there
is only one good move for black here and
that's not the one you're considering
unless you're consider considering rook
to h5
uh bringing rook into the game would
rook to h5 with a double attack on the
bishop is the way to go but here
instead of that we have king to f8 and
king to f8 will simply not do
another thing some of you have
considered is knight captures on e5
after this bishop to e5 but this doesn't
work for a very
uh particular reason and that's rook
captures on f6 and there is no good move
here
uh g captures on f6 then we're going to
play d captures on e5
and now e captures and f6 is coming and
those two pawns are going to be
insane and the problem is you cannot
capture it
uh because then comes knight captures
and d5 and this piece sacrifice is just
brutal uh here for example c captures
bishop captures with
check you're gonna play king f8 now rook
f7 check and
there is no good move here if you go
king to g8 uh then you go
in a line of fire of the bishop and here
you're just gonna get
checkmated rook captures with the
discover to check uh king f8 g7
check now king has to go to e8 and then
you capture bringing a queen into the
game or a rook whatever you prefer
uh or writer whichever you prefer so
here after rook to f7 check you would
have to go king to e8 but this isn't all
that much better just g7
attacking the rook rook the g8 and now
rook captures on b7
attacking the rook and there's no uh no
uh safety square for this rook you have
to play something so let's say captures
on g7
captures on g7 and now rook to d8
attacking the the bishop here
uh but it doesn't matter it's not really
a trade just bishop c6 check and after
king f8 you're gonna grab the piece and
now of course the white position is
completely winning
so this is the the poison that is hidden
in the position
after bishop to e5 so here the opponent
did not find rook to h5 he played king
to f8 but now
again it doesn't work rook to f7 checked
by morphy
and now what do you play uh it's the
same stuff if king to e8 we just run
into this very unpleasant
bishop to c7 cutting of the king from
escaping to the queen side the rook
prevents the king from going anywhere
and the rook
rook to e1 will be deadly here uh you
could try defending let's say bishop e6
but still just rook to a1
if knight to f8 now guarding the bishop
doesn't matter just bishop d6 we're
going to remove the defender
and that's it black has nothing to play
here if knight captures here
preparing to capture the rook just rook
captures and be some
there's still no saving this bishop uh
all of these squares are now covered by
the by the dark square bishop so it
wouldn't really help for knight to go
anywhere there
king d8 bishop the bishop is lost and
that's just it
so instead after rook to f7 uh we don't
have king
e8 instead we have king to g8 but now
uh only now feel free to pause the video
and win this game for morphe while i
give you a couple of seconds
and in case some of you were wondering
the reason why i'm wearing a hoodie is
because
we are playing against mr hoodie guy
here and whenever we
don't know uh who the player is or we
don't have a photo of a chess player
then we will of course honor him by by
wearing a hoodie
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding the
crushing knight
captures on d5 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
yeah this is what was played and we're
not just going to play knight to d5
uh we're also gonna mention what uh our
good friend
laurenthal said about this move because
as you all know loyantal was following
all of the games that morphe played
because he's such a
uh powerful opponent uh logan said about
this move
this is uh one of those brilliant
combinations in which mr morphy has made
himself so famous
and which occur with equal frequency in
his blindfold games as in those that he
has conducted with board and
men before him so this is what our good
friend lovental
thinks of knight captures on the e5 and
it is indeed crushing so here
uh you don't really have a good move c
captures on d5 was played
but now bishop captures on d5
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries here the black king has no
squares
uh and here again the problem with
capturing is just rook captures and g7
checkmate so this is out of the question
uh knight the b6 was played attacking
the bishop now one more time but here
morphy just
retreated with bishop to b3 and it was
in this position that uh portia resigned
the game and the wonderful victory for
paul charles murphy and this is uh
uh this is uh well everyone's favorite
kind of
victory you win by retreating someone
attacks your piece you retreat it
and your opponent resigns it's just uh
amazing stuff
so here you don't have a move any move
ends in either you know severe material
loss or in checkmate
and even if you go for rook to h5 which
black should have played
like the entire game here it is
insufficient because now any move
is just check so here rook captures an
f6 for example with
check and you don't really have anything
here uh you could go king to h8 but then
rook f8
check rook is forced to capture and then
rook captures on f8 with
checkmate and that's all there is so
uh after bishop to b3 a beautiful
retreating uh
move that finishes the game morphy wins
the first game over the simultaneous
exhibition and we
are going to cover some other games from
this uh very nice samuel and the only
then we will discuss
the the results uh of the simul and what
happens with the continuation of the
match with the daniel harvest
uh so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
and that are still enjoying the paul
morphy saga for those of you who are new
to the channel or just joining in uh the
first link in the description below will
take you to the beginning of the morphe
saga so you can enjoy
everything that happened so far uh and
follow our hero to his great victories
uh so uh i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank uh
flavio luis corparios mr hoodie guy uh
alexandre capone uh emmanuel vidmer and
the chess heroes kickstarter for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and um
i will see you guys uh with some more uh
of the good stuff uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day